what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the 10 deaths of wolverine
x deaths of wolverine basically the
story of morax and again like i didn't
think you guys would love the first one
as much as you did it was kind of crazy
like you i was like do you guys really
want me to continue this because it
seems a little weird you guys are like
yes
i figured so many of you guys are just
going to be like no i don't want to see
this anymore uh so here's the thing
right again the whole idea behind this
is that this story largely follows more
mctaggart right the whole thing behind
this basically being after her ousting
where she was basically booted from uh
from kokoa and basically sent kind of
given a little bit of leeway or a little
bit of lead time and that mystique was
like i'm gonna find you and kill you
just so you know
she's basically been on the run ever
since what she ends up doing is
basically running up on a gas station
where some poor sap starts making
conversation with the wrong person and
basically she grabs a burner phone ties
the guy up duct tapes his mouth and then
calls jane foster now remember jane
foster was the one who initially did an
examination on maura because she was
like coughing up blood different things
like that she didn't fully know what was
going on and they ended up determining
that she basically had cancer but while
maura has been on the run jane foster
has been investigating this whole thing
which by the way gas prices are three
dollars and 20 cents must be nice right
like gas prices are four bucks where i'm
at
but what ends up happening is jane
foster basically realizes that with this
cancer that morgan mctaggart has that
it's got fluoronic matter that's woven
directly into it what this indicates is
maura may or may not have cancer but
whatever it is that's killing her
basically came from cocoa in effect you
could make an argument she was poisoned
and that's really what it looks to be
here that's what it really really looks
like here is that she was either slowly
being poisoned or was suddenly poisoned
and now it's basically killing her and
so in response to that of course she
basically ends up kind of going on the
run and while she's doing that you have
this alternate version of wolverine who
shows up attacked some guys who are
basically shark hunting kills them all
or really just makes him like jump in
the water and leaves them there but i
mean come on like he leaves them
stranded in the middle of the ocean
these guys are going to die uh and then
takes the boat and basically heads after
maura mctaggart now for maura herself
this is cool man i love the way benjamin
percy does this right it was it was one
thing to show us more at mctaggart in
terms of like how ruthless she could be
regarding the whole plan she had right
one of the things that was established
in hickman's inferno is that up until
that point it was largely believed that
more mctaggart was working with xavier
and magneto in order to engineer a
circumstance whereby mutants could
basically survive the future holocaust
they would go through and facing off
against uh basically like the post-human
race so kind of like evolved humans as
well as like machines but the reality of
the plan is that morgan mchaggart
basically expected or at least intended
to engineer mutants in such a way to
where she would basically wipe them out
where they would just be born without a
mutant gene and then there would be no
war between humans and mutants and
post-humans because there would be no
mutants so the war could never happen in
the first place there's one thing to
give us that right and just say damn man
that's kind of cold-blooded dude what
she does here is nuts man this is some
crazy stuff so check this out she comes
to this realization that the means by
which she's being tracked is largely
because of the phalanx arm or the tech
knock arm that she has right this is a
piece of technology that came basically
came from like warlock it's living
machinery is really what it is and so in
realizing that she's like the only way
to do this is to basically cut it off
now remember she has this because she
lost her arm so she's literally gonna
cut off this artificial arm that she has
this chick not even lying to you guys
right not even lying this girl feels
like she literally charges up an iron
right so like she turns an iron on
basically starts heating it up she fills
a bathtub with water and iodine right
which iodine is really good for like
killing bacteria and so on gets into
this thing right like naked is the day
she was born and then drinks a whole
bunch of whiskey because lord knows
she's gonna need it like heats up a
knife and then cuts her arm off and then
uses an iron to cauterize the wound let
me tell you something man that's some
hardcore and i'm not even lying
no one could say that maura mctaggart is
not badass after seeing her do that that
is nuts like i was i was sitting here
reading through this and i was like
jesus benjamin percy you're not pulling
any punches son do more of me taggert
man like here's i have a whole new level
of respect for mctagger now like it's
like okay before she was like a thinker
but like it was one of those things
where like she's she's got like a mind
and like she wants to do stuff but you
kind of have this feeling that like when
it all hits the fan she's gonna like run
and cry because like reality caught up
to her and it was too much for her to
handle now son man this woman's gotta
wear accounts
this is nuts now because mystique is
using the technork arm of uh moore may
taggart to track her of course mystique
shows up at this hotel pretending to be
some old man who's been traveling
looking for his daughter when the guy
tells him like look it's like 50 bucks
right paying cash this guy's like look
man you know i'll take your money i'll
take the hundred bucks you're going to
give me instead of the 50. but i'm not
giving you any questions and and
mystique right ever the person with the
best social skills right just knows how
to talk to people literally says oh
really like i think you will right
everybody talks eventually it's just a
matter of how many bones they want to
have broken and she takes it to this guy
right like literally like she puts a
like a like a knife in his shoulder
right broke a few of his bones and then
literally like disguised herself as the
guy goes to the room of warren mctaggart
and again more mctaggart man being a
badass dude so she basically knew that
mystique was going to catch her
eventually and then basically plants a
bomb under the bed and makes it look
like she's in that bed basically with
like you know blood on the sheets and
all that kind of stuff the whole thing
explodes right the whole thing like
literally goes off and it kills mystique
right but remember death is not an
absolute anymore the death of mystique
and deaths in the x-men stories are not
necessarily plot devices they basically
allow riders to get away with things
that they wouldn't normally be able to
get away with that's kind of the big
thing that i want to iterate here right
death serving as a plot device is one of
those things where like when superman
dies like damn superman died he got beat
to death by doomsday oh my god is this
catastrophic thing it's like the saddest
thing ever and that was like the thing
that came after right like oh my god
colossus died when he sacrificed himself
to develop a cure for the legacy virus
in the late 1990s oh my god this person
died and the writers build it up that
way like it's the saddest moment ever
because this person died and they have
like a funeral in the comics and all
that and then the person like comes back
the good thing about what they're doing
in the x-men comics now is they're like
yeah mystique got blown up but like
she's gonna come back right like they're
just gonna they're gonna resurrect her
so it's cool to see them using death as
a means as a kind of a storytelling
device as opposed to just being like a
way to drum up sales right and just make
it all seem really sad and take away
from the meaning of it and so of course
you know again we know misty is going to
come back but one of the things that
happens is we kind of switch over to
destiny for a second irene adler love
irene adler i've been a fan of her ever
since i started reading comics if you
had her information you'd basically know
exactly what to do in order to like
avoid one all the pitfalls that the
mutants were going to face and two
basically be able to conquer the world
but the thing about this is she of
course kind of muses about how mystique
believed that like the future was
negotiable that somehow the future can
be changed and the response of destiny
is no like the future is basically an
absolute thing i know exactly where
we're headed she doesn't really give us
a whole lot of information she says but
in the end not all is lost right that a
figure keeps materializing in the mind
of destiny basically this uh this kind
of man in black as she describes him
death himself now this is important
because what this does is it seems to
hint at a few things one that yes that
basically maura mctaggart has been
ousted by the entirety of the mutant
community or at least those who are in
the quiet council nobody else really
knew about her so they couldn't really
oust her but two it seems like she
really is hell-bent on effectively
nullifying the mutant population that
motivation hasn't gone away that it is
coming from a place of genuine like love
and concern she wants to save the mutant
race but it's one of those things where
it's like in order to save mutants she
basically has to end mutants so whether
it comes from a place of altruism or it
comes from a place of just being a
terrible human being her actions are
basically the same as orcas and
everybody else the desire to get rid of
the mutant population one of the things
to understand is we could potentially be
looking at another house of m type
situation not in the sense that like
you're going to see the the you know
scarlet witch lose their mind and you
know take away 98 of the mutant powers
population but in the sense that we
could be looking at like a wholesale
consolidation of the mutant race to make
it more manageable and really to bring
the comics closer in line with whatever
it is that happens in the marvel
cinematic universe regarding the x-men
right so i wouldn't be surprised if at
the end of all this this whole era of
the x-men krakow is gone right i mean
keep in mind when we were talking about
dark rain and all that stuff which we
need to go back and cover all the x-men
stories from the mid-2000s god i have
adhd so bad uh one of the things that
happened is the x-men left westchester
they left new york they took up
residence on an island called utopia off
the coast of san francisco and that
didn't last too long right they
eventually ended up going back and then
now you basically have them on kakoa so
again it's one of these things where
this whole thing about kokoa will likely
come to an end
when that'll happen we don't fully know
but we know that eventually it will the
other part of this is that the pod that
this evil version or this dark version
of wolverine emerged from is basically
being investigated by uh by forge and
really just kind of being followed up on
with like jean grey and professor x
right they're kind of keeping an eye on
forge as he's doing all this and one of
the things that ford says is like this
pod whatever this is the biology doesn't
match up basically this thing is
thousands of years older than krakowa so
how it could possibly be on krakowa and
us not know about it or having just
recently discovered it doesn't make any
sense right like we would have noticed
this when krakow formed the only
alternative here is that this is
basically an object out of time that it
ended up here but it's either not from
our time and it's from a different a
different place in time entirely and
somehow just manifested here we don't
know like i have no real idea and
honestly benjamin percy ain't giving us
any details like that's literally all we
get on this thing but then at that point
you switch back to wolverine and this is
why i think we start getting clues on
what's going on with wolverine himself
that what happens here is that when
wolverine emerges right when he shows up
at what was basically the hotel where
everything went down between uh mystique
and maura mctaggart then of course cops
are on the scene the fire department's
on the scene putting out the fire all
that kind of stuff you know emergency
services basically what you would expect
and where a couple of cops are stupid
enough to try to stop wolverine of
course he ends up getting past you know
getting past the two of them and then
goes in there and basically finds what
is the burned corpse right the charred
corpse of mystique as well as
essentially the arm of mora mctaggart
that was left behind and then ultimately
you end up seeing these kinds of things
where he starts talking about this idea
of like the phalanx and like teknark and
so on and so forth and like this kind of
machine component and different things
along those lines and so what this looks
like here right once he basically
accesses a kind of terminal and
basically starts downloading information
on where more mick haggard would most
likely go which is basically the
epiphany labs right we learned about
that in some of the previous stories
that of course he leaves and goes on his
way what this looks like here this is
one of these keep in mind the phalanx in
the the house and powers of x storyline
when jonathan hickman first kicked off
the x-men the phalanx had seemingly just
kind of become this hyper-evolved uh
organism right that right now in the
present day the phalanx just exists out
there it's a kind of machine organism
that is like very similar to the board
from like star trek right they exist to
like quote unquote better themselves and
assimilate the various things around
them they've been successful in some
ways they've been unsuccessful in most
ways for example like the whole cameron
hodge storyline way back in the 1990s
which was just an amazing storyline when
cameron hodge became the leader of the
phalanx that was great there's a lot of
like those older marvel stories that we
didn't cover we should bring back a day
where we basically just cover like the
older marvel stuff right like the the
x-men from like the mid-2000s so we we
covered stuff like messiah complex and
all that but like the things in between
um and then going into like hope summers
and like the 12 lights and all that kind
of stuff which basically dead ends into
the story of like avengers versus x-men
going into like the cosmic stories right
so like we did annihilation and like
infinity and all that kind of stuff but
we never did like war of kings or realm
of kings or anything like that like we
should we should do those stories like
that would be legit just like dedicated
day and just like just cover that stuff
you know essentially in sequence but the
thing about this is that when more
mchagert looks in this whole situation
she says like i've lived and i've died
and i've lived right over and over again
the mutants always meet their end they
wanted this time to be different and
they got their wish i've seen the future
i just didn't think it would get here so
fast and so what this looks like is that
in that far-flung future when the
phalanx had basically become this just
kind of almost omnipresent figure that
would actually travel around the cosmos
very similar to the way the celestials
did and when they reached the race or
came across a race that it achieved a
high enough level of technological
advancement and basically merged that
technology with themselves and would be
absorbed into the phalanx it looks like
they've effectively sent one of their
own into the past and that's what it
looks like with wolverine now again we
don't know that right we don't know if
that's the case i'm just guessing here
right we won't know until we get further
along into the story but regardless man
this okay so you guys were you guys were
right when you said like we should just
let this play out and just see how it
goes it's getting really good it's
getting really really good so much so
that i think it's actually teetering on
being better than the 10 lives of
wolverine but again these are really
really good stories so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace